ah
Walter
what's up five fans welcome to fallout
fours Robot Wars in celebration of 404s
new automatron dlc we have gathered the
wastelands finest fighters to scrap for
your amusement I am Dave juggernaut
jewett and I'm Kate grapple fist gray
and what a show we've got for you
tonight we have four fighters yes four
fighters all in the arena to fight for
all your amusements so let's get it on
our first robot is gray matter so named
because of the brain in the jar fun fact
about gray matter he hates cats his
weapons include a minigun very nice and
an arm drill unorthodox I like it he's
gonna be fighting a group of thirty of
the finest Raiders today all the scum
that we could find how think he's gonna
get on quite frankly I think he's got a
bit of a weak spot considering that his
brain is in a jar well let's see if they
can crack it the fight is about to begin
three two one all right so we are off
he's opened up real fast with a shot of
radiation I believe that there's fire
already kay there is fire already the
whole stadium is ablaze I've got to say
he's looking pretty intense so far he's
taken down at least one Raider that I
can see exposed him into chunks
he's got bits coming off his armor but
that doesn't seem to be affecting too
much he's taking the hits pretty well if
you ask me though that fire that that
brain fluid has got to be boiling he's
he's interestingly stayed at distance so
far but he's getting a little bit close
that arm drill not coming into play
quite yet I've got a wonder how many
mini gun rounds he has well he's taken
down at least half the Raiders at the
moment and the rest are down on one knee
trying to take him out I mean some of
those ones on the floor could be lying
prone but I think they are in fact dead
there's one two left
last one with a headshot beautiful play
by grey matter and he just wanders off
he doesn't have a damn and our next
fighter is hag one of our most
terrifying combatants tonight she wears
a skull don't know who it belongs to
but a pony she likes to hug but with her
armaments to shish kebobs I'm not sure I
want an embrace from this fearsome lady
and tonight she is gonna be fighting two
of the most ferocious death claws that
we could find on shore notice a green
one a grey one they're all going to end
up red the fights happening three
to one see the sad thing about hag is
that she's sort of like a fiery Edward
Scissorhands maybe she just wants to
love these death tours maybe that's her
curse
she has been gifted programmed with a
love for hugging but they're not the
ability to do so she's made of metal her
arms are constantly on fire and she's
got a laser beam coming out of her face
not sure the death call like that pretty
sure that was a crippling shot and he's
on fire
I'm gonna be honest that that that skull
there might be the skull of her dead
creator maybe it's a super sad story
that we just don't I hope so because
that is a backstory I can get behind but
she has already taken one death cord
down it seems put much of a fight
maybe this green one can fare a little
bit better it's doing pretty well so far
we can't see the health bar but I think
he might be going down that's definitely
a staggering hit she's got the eye laser
or not not a hit there she seemed to try
and fire it through the door at me but I
mean I'm gonna just assume that was a
mistake and hopefully she's gonna deal
the killing blow soon if you've got no
laser do you know how to work it or is
it just a thing that happens to you like
Cyclops there's an accidental shot the
deathclaw looks like it's faltering
maybe this could be it
there's a few more line to those shish
kabobs oh the head pops off and hag just
looks on no eye care in the world just
think of her hugs our next fighter is my
personal favorite it's fruit he's called
fruit because he looks like and enjoys
oranges but another fun fact about fruit
is he lives in constant pain when I
suppose he's got no eyes legs arms
nothing they've all been pulled apart
hopefully these dogs will take some
mercy on him I'm not sure how he's gonna
fight three you know standard normal
dogs with no arms with no arms but you
know he's a robot and they're three tiny
dogs so I'm sure he'd be fine let's get
into the fight three two one alright so
his tactics so far is to stand there Hey
okay this is just the right fighter I
mean this is the cutest bye ever I think
the dogs are after me because he looks
like a ball I'm not sure oh one of
fruits fans is in the stand defending
him who we all know too late is it
possible for something with no eyes to
look sad can somebody get fruit
just check them in the bin it's fine our
final fighter a fan favorite sir
kilowatts celebrity star X star of Robot
Wars and enjoys cross-stitching
brochure how he does it with a hammer
saw missiles fat man and gas cannons for
arms you know when there's a will
there's a way
and he will be facing three of the
finest super mutant behemoths I'm
surprised these guys haven't just left
because nothing's keeping them in this
Stadium Deadpool too big three two one
let's go so you can see here that the
behemoths are taking a rather aggressive
stance pummeling and throwing rocks at
poor circular log but he's standing up
pretty well considering they're twice
his size
I'm quite surprised because if there's
rhythm he's actually putting up a pretty
good defense he's got this electricity
field around him that is stunning them
slightly but considering the size of
these guys weapons and the stomping of
their giant feet he's actually
deflecting some of their attacks
although I'm quite surprised he hasn't
used his heavy weapons yet more going in
for a melee approach he seems to be more
on the defensive than the offensive he
hasn't actually managed to hit many of
them yet he's sort of doing some quite
ineffective punch moves which don't
actually seem to be connecting with them
even though as I've said they're twice
his size it is surprising he is up
against the wall so it's not in the best
position for circular lock he is landing
some punches with his hammer soft fist
though oh whoa oh that was that was a
strategic maneuver from Circular he has
got himself out of a bound but oh no the
behemoth is up on the stands he's gonna
have that height advantage now flying
down blows on sir kill a lot from up
high let's see how he deals with this
going on he looks like he might even be
cracking into each taking down one
behemoth okay that is one less yes to
deal with maybe this fight can turn in
his favor now you see what do you seems
to be doing here is focusing one at a
time although authenticate that is
because one of them we just turns a
fight around one two yeah with a fat man
and just ended things early and it's
just left the stands presumably to
reload and you know hit the bar I'll
take you on he can try the juggernaut
fee is no one
so those were our prizefighters fruit a
bit of a disappointment but the rest
stood up pretty well remember that you
can check us out on Twitter I'm at how
not to draw and I am at a regular Dave
thank you fans for joining us tonight
watching this bloodbath of metal mucus
and flesh if you want to keep watching
all these prize fights in the future
make sure you check us out with the
hashtag gs fallouts and for all your
gruesome blood sports keep it GameSpot
com